un discurso en la haya sobre la temática
de la soberanía económica e industrial
de la Unión Europea discurso que fue
rápidamente
interrumpido por dos manifestantes que
lo increparon sobre la reforma
pensionada ante lo cual el presidente
tranquilamente les dijo que estaba
abierto a un debate social sobre todo
cuando se vive en una democracia luego
continuó ya con su discurso en donde
habló del tema de la necesidad de que
Europa pues sea dueña de su propio
destino y no dependa de países terceros
algo que había quedado muy en claro con
la pandemia de Kobe 19 en cuanto por
ejemplo al tema de los medicamentos
producidos en países terceros Como por
ejemplo la India también habló de la
necesidad de descarbonizar la economía y
para esto se necesita una estrategia
nueva para que la Unión Europea dependa
mucho menos de las energías fósiles
entre los otros temas que abordó el
presidente habló el proteccionismo un
tema que puede ser un poco al Hip álgido
Pero dijo que era importante en muchos
casos
proteger ciertos intereses vitales de
los países del bloque es decir temas
Como por ejemplo en cuanto a seguridad
ciberseguridad o incluso
infraestructuras que puedan ser muy
vulnerables de los últimos temas ya que
abordó uno de ellos tiene que ver con el
comercio un comercio mucho más
equitativo no solamente entre miembros o
sea de la Unión Europea sino también con
otros socios países terceros y terminó
diciendo que es importante que Europa
trabaje para unir para reunir aún más a
los europeos y para esto se necesita
mucha más cooperación y más coordinación
ahora Emmanuel macompes continua su
visita a los Países Bajos terminará el
día de mañana después de reunirse con el
Primer Ministro de ese país mar